[Music]
let's go out to bwood South Carolina and
talk to the great and wonderful Jasmine
what's up
Jasmine hi Dr John what's
happening uh not much it's a beautiful
day here today that's fantastic it's a
rainy gray sad cold day here which I
kind of love what's
up so I have been an relationship with
my boyfriend for the past 5 years okay
and recently I gave him a marriage
ultimatum oh no you didn't did you
really I did how's that working out for
you well we're coming up to the end of
that I guess line no way I'm honestly
not sure what to do how long how long
did you give him in your
ultimative three months and so how many
days are
left uh just over 30 I would I would
would I would break up right now do you
all live together we do yeah I would say
hey I'm gonna go ahead and move out this
weekend and I love you I'll probably
always love you and it's been so
great wow is that not what you thought I
was gonna
say no I honestly I was hoping you'd say
more but I honestly expected it here's
here's what I'm saying that number one I
dated my wife for 5 years off and on we
broke up a whole bunch we're in college
out of all that so the the time doesn't
bother me um some couples stay for six
years seven years some couple stayed for
three months right um that's that's just
life and I'm sure there's some data
there I really don't care to read it it
just is what it is but for whatever
reason and you've heard me say this on
the show a million times behavior is a
language and for whatever reason he is
telling you I've got other priorities
that are not you right
now and your priorities are security and
safety your priorities are maybe him
maybe they're a bigger Global picture
maybe they're hey my clock is ticking
hey there who knows what your priorities
are but they're different and my concern
about a marriage ultimatum either by
this date or I'm out is even if he says
okay will you marry me and you go oh my
gosh
yes he will always know he entered into
this thing this forever thing um being
dragged behind a car and you'll always
know I had to drag him into
this and I just worry about the the
longterm how often that resurfaces I
didn't even want to do this you force
this is this how you're going to handle
all of our problems um it just creates
Downstream ripples that I don't even
know if you can see them yet so tell me
tell me tell me about this guy why do
you want to marry
him or another question why do you want
to force him to marry
you honestly he's a great guy he um he's
a great dad to my
kids um he's not their biological dad
but he's been there for the last five
years um and okay you just gave me two
things that have nothing to do with how
well yall work together romantically and
how yall are building a life together
that is true so give me that
info honestly we're struggling on that
info no tell me no way really and I'm
not laughing at you I'm laughing with
you of course you're struggling tell me
about
it we're struggling um the communication
isn't like it used to be we're not
communicating much at all we're mostly
talking in regards to the kids and
nothing more honestly at this point
right um Intimacy in all forms or have
been out the window okay yeah we're
we're not in the best of place and so
what about this is marriage going to
solve I don't honestly I'm not sure I
don't I don't think it will solve
anything I think in the back of my mind
that was my way of getting it out which
sounds horrible now that I say it out
loud getting out of this
relationship yeah oh sweetheart tell me
tell me more about
that I love him dearly I just don't see
how it can be fixed at this point and I
figured well maybe if I throw marriage
out there and I give him this ultimatum
and he doesn't you know come on board
then I'll say well you were the reason
why
man that's that's I I I'm I'm giving you
high five for the courage to say that
out loud most people would cower behind
dishonesty there and you're not you're a
person of Integrity even though you're
doing a kind of a shady thing you're a
person of Integrity while you're doing
it right
um why don't you believe enough in
yourself to call
it because of my
kids so you want to be able to C to
manufacture a story that hey honey hey
kids he left us just like your dad
did no I I don't I you're right I need
to have the courage to say something and
I feel like I've been telling him over
the years for the last honestly two
years that I've been unhappy that we
need to talk more that we need to try
counseling and he just doesn't seem
receptive he keeps telling me how
important work is and other things
around the house are and I'm like we
don't even go on dates like what's going
on what happened with your your
children's
father uh so my first husband is my is
my oldest's father um he was very
abusive so that relationship didn't
work and my daughter's father was just
never in the picture Okay so you have
two kids
yeah are you sick of are you cuz you've
been alone
twice and with different relationships
and a child and you've also been alone
for a couple of years inside of this
relationship are you sick of being
alone I think so yeah I'm almost sick of
it for you I can't it's not my job I
can't do that for you but I'm almost I'm
heartbroken for
you
are you scared to be a single mom with
two kids
again definitely tell me about that it
was it was my biggest fear when I had my
daughter and I didn't expect that I
would be a single mom of two by myself
and when it happened it was just like
okay you know what let's swallow this
pill and move on and handle it and it
just happens to be that I met him five
months in after my daughter was born so
five months into being the single mom of
two I met him
and it's like I said it's it's been a
great relationship up until a certain
point and I I don't know how to fix it
or what to do to nudge it over in the
right direction has it been a great
relationship up until two years ago or
was
it did it begin in chaos and it provided
you a like a a life raft in a Raging
Sea and and no it was good I wouldn't
say that I would say it was good I was
you know doing my own thing I had just
bought a house I was living in a new
state everything was fresh and going
well between me and my kids the school
was going good like I had
this this pretty settled life and
everything was okay and I just kind of
met him and things blossomed then I sold
my house I moved to a new state to be
closer and you know it just it took a
while I felt like throughout our
relationship everything was kind of done
on his terms and the more that happened
the more resentment kind of build it up
there you
go how long's that been building for a
long time I bet huh it's because listen
when you when you when when you hear
this when it comes out I want you to pay
special attention to that last maybe
minute and a
half when you told me about having your
second kid and buying a house and school
was settled your whole voice
changes you remember Walking Tall even
though you are in a really difficult
situation financially have two little
kids you got no
help and then when you start talking
about I sold my house I moved to a new
state everything in your vocal tone
changes as though you're getting dragged
back
underwater and then didn't surprise me
at all real quick you mentioned then the
resentment starts
building that you're basically you and
your two kids are a cog in his
life does that feel does that feel
right
yeah and here's the thing I I I I
wouldn't do this job I wouldn't work
with married couples behind closed doors
I wouldn't do that if I didn't think
there was always a possibility a chance
back not not back a chance forward a
chance to build something
new but it sounds to me like you've been
trying to do that for a long time and he
just has no interest in it and I mean to
be frank why would he you're probably
not going
anywhere
right yeah my my friends keep saying the
same thing they've been saying the same
thing for the last two years you're
probably not going anywhere you've been
saying you're going to go and you're
still here yeah you use that threat so
many times when you said you got 90 days
to marry me or I'm out he's like okay
sure you want Arby's you like like
okay
so what happens tonight if you sat down
and said hey I think we're
done I love you you've been so great to
my kids last five years you're really
the dad that they
know and we met in a really vulnerable
moment for me in a vulnerable season for
me and I'm so grateful that you were
there for me but you don't love me you
don't want to be
married what do you say as adults we
call
this we'll figure out the finances and
I'll figure out what to do and we'll go
from
there because you'll have a legal claim
to some of the house you have a legal
claim to some of the assets and all that
stuff y'all can be adults about it and
split it up because you're not even
married or you can go to court and this
whole thing is going to be in
Nightmare what does he say if you say
that does he sound relieved do you sound
relieved I think alson relieved and
he'll sound kind of like what what's
been going on like he's been out of the
loop in a sense but he hasn't
been would there be a possibility that
you could walk back like hey I've asked
you to go to counseling nine times in
the last two
years I even concocted a story that said
I was breaking up with you if you didn't
marry me and now a month out like what
like I'm we're
done we haven't held hands in two years
we haven't been on a date in 3
years I have no friends we don't have
couples over we don't see what I'm
saying like is there a way just to kind
of lay out the data
there yeah there
is so what's your
reluctance do you have a job I do you
make good
money I do
so financially you can walk away you can
go get an apartment today take two
kids or after Thanksgiving you can take
your two kids you could do that huh but
it's my house so he'd be the one moving
out that's what I'm talking
about so you can give him 30
days see I mean see what I'm
saying no you're absolutely right what's
the
hesitation if you gave me any like spark
in the darkness that he wants to work on
this that he's that that y'all have just
come to an impass you're not
communicating well intimacy life's over
you want some stability he's out just
doing his thing whatever you're tired of
being a girlfriend what if you told me
that there's any sort of Hope there I'd
be all in all
in but it sounds like you broke up with
him two years ago and you just lived in
the same house with him and then you're
trying to at the very end get him to
break up with you so you can feel a
little bit self-righteous in a way
that's cruel it's cruel to your kids
it's cruel to him and more important
it's cruel to
you I just think you're worth more than
that I think if this relationship's over
it needs an adult to say hey I'm just
going to call what
is there's always a doctor it has to be
the doctor that that comes into an
emergency room when a patient has passed
everybody's been working everybody's
sweating everybody sometimes there tears
in people's eyes there's there's gauze
every everywh there's blood everywhere
there's instruments everywhere it's a
doctor's job to come in and call
it time of death is official at this
time and if that's where you are be the
adult here clearly you're you you're an
adult in other places because you're a
mom two kids you're a good professional
where you make good money like I think
it's
time and maybe he looks at you and says
I'll do anything if he does great you
can say cool we got to build something
completely new starting
today
hope that's the case I really do thanks
for the call
Jasmine a best the best the best of luck
to you I'd love to know how that
conversation goes if you'll holler back
at us and let us
know